dr. Robbins dr. Robbins dr. Robin
well if you're going to make it doctor
hello well how's the world greatest
newspaper man that's more looking for
news say about the youngster you're
going to be alright
yes sir no tragic ending this time this
little girl's gonna get wet
thanks to dr. heartfully here well
you're too generous doctor huh
well the real life-saving was done
before she got to the hospital well I
don't get it doctor what's the story
here's what I mean Jerry the real hero
is somebody whose name you and I have
never known the Good Samaritan that gave
that little girl first aid at the scene
of the accident
yes Jerry that person was one of the
thousands well the people always trying
to help that is most of them - now you
can't exist I know Jerry most people are
willing to help but that alone isn't
enough it takes something more than just
willingness to save a life what well
after all we can't all be doctors it has
to be but if everyone who is willing to
help them an accident or emergency where
armed was just a little well just the
bare basic essentials of first-aid a
great many lives would be saved if
everyone if you and the owner and you
know and you would take the time to
learn what to do before the doctor
arrived know what to look for
know what to do know how to do it these
are the essentials of birthdays now
let's see how these principles apply
first in regard to wound a sharp edged
knife
a broken bottle a sharp piece of metal
shattered windshield
never a few of the causes of wounds
wounds that bleed bleeding can be fatal
but it can be stopped effectively with
simple first aid treatment there are two
main types of bleeding that can occur
bleeding from arteries and bleeding from
veins to recognize each type you should
know how the blood circulates in the
body the heart acts as a potting station
the right side of the heart pumps blood
to the lungs in the lungs the blood
picks up oxygen which is necessary to
sustain life the blood that returned to
the left side of the heart where it is
pumped to all parts of the body through
a system of cubes known as arteries then
through a network of tiny blood vessels
called capillaries and back again to the
heart through another system of vessels
the veins when one of the arteries is
cut bleeding is serious I've ever seen
the way water spurts from the hand pump
that is the way of blood spurts from an
artery which has been cut
blood spurts before from the womb it's
time the heart beats this type of
bleeding must be stopped quickly to save
life in most cases bleeding can be
stopped effectively by simple first aid
measures such as pressure apply directly
on the wall if this does not stop the
bleeding
apply finger pressure sometimes called
digital pressure between the heart and
the wound another way is to use a
tourniquet similarly placed both methods
compress and close off the artery in all
cases of serious bleeding be sure
to call the doctor to return to digital
pressure there are several points on
each side of the body where the arteries
lie close to a bone it's at these points
where pressure is most effective
arterial bleeding can be controlled on
the scalp and on the upper portion of
the head by finger pressure just in
front of the middle portion of the inner
this stops the escape of blood from the
artery serving this particular area
blood flowing from a cut artery in the
lower portion of the face may be
controlled by pressure and the underside
of the jawbone just in front of the
angle of the jaw this cuts off the
supply of blood to this portion of the
face arterial bleeding from the neck can
be controlled by pressure on the
bleeding side of the neck after the
thumb against the nape of the neck and
with the fingers press alongside the
windpipe draw the spinal column
care must be taken us to press against
the windpipe for bleeding around the
shoulder or armpit then head slightly
toward the bleeding side and bring brand
pressure to bear with the thumb behind
the center of the collarbone the flow
through this artery will thus be
effectively controlled
arterial bleeding of the arm at any
point below the armpit may be controlled
by pressure on the blood vessel against
the bone of the upper arm
thus compressing the artery and checking
the flow of blood if an artery cut in
the leg or thigh
bleeding may be stopped by pressing
firmly against the thigh bone high up on
the inner side of the thigh that's
shutting off the blood supply to the
limb below this point when bleeding from
the arm or leg cannot be controlled by
digital pressure you know the tourniquet
a triangle of bandage
: into Acrobat make some excellent turn
again as does a roller bandage Stuckey
our tank achieved even a necktie will do
if nothing else is available but never
use anything such as a wire rope which
may cut into the skin and cause injury
when using a tourniquet direct pressure
on the artery is desirable a small roll
of bandage or folded gauze is excellent
for this purpose never use everything
car or with sharp edges better to apply
they turn to get without a pad at all
suck the roll of bandage or pad directly
over the artery wrap whatever material
you are using for the tourniquet around
the limb twice tire loose enough place
the short stick over this knot tie it
securely in place now turn the stick so
that the tourniquet tightest twist the
stick only enough to stop the bleeding
this causes the pad to press firmly
against the artery forming a berry of
tests which the blood cannot flow a
tourniquet must be listed at regular
intervals of 15 minutes to avoid
permanent damage to the tissue
everything starts again tighten the
tourniquet remember to loosen the
tourniquet effort at 15 minutes and
tightness again only a bleeding resume a
condition known as shock may be present
in all injuries and very frequently and
severe bleeding the vital functions of
the body are slowed down shaft may
result in death therefore while waiting
for the doctor trick the victim for shot
immediately after stopping the bleeding
a person in shock
tail has a call clammy skin with rapid
pumps and brands irregularly keep him
quiet lying down weather threatened
completely in blankets or the cook or
anything to keep him warm apply hot
water bubbles carefully rest bags have
heated Sanders so take care of all that
you don't burn the injured another thing
to remember and treating shock is
possessive kick the body flex and raise
the foot of the bed cut or stretcher so
the head is lower than the rest of the
body if the injured is lying on
something that cannot be ready kick a
stick legs and thighs raise keep it
lying quietly and let coughs up blood or
has difficulty in breathing or has no
blade does allow him to sit up at this
point stimulants are important one of
the most effective is aromatic spirits
of ammonia one teaspoonful in 1/2 glass
of water hot coffee or tea also are
excellent stimulants and now that it
will in supplying heat if he is
unconscious never try to force him to
drink an unconscious person may be
revived by having a stimulant which can
be imitated such as ammonia inhale or
aromatic spirits of ammonia are nadenka
cheap simply all of the handkerchief
near the nose for a few seconds or
you're smelling salts shock may be
avoided
yet these steps are taken in time so
those are the important things feel to
do for a person suffering from shock
keep him warm
keep him lying quietly on his back with
his head low
his feet and give him stimulus all these
things sounds simple and they are but
that simple first aid steps taken before
the doctor comes have saved many lives
and now let's go back and take up the
second type of bleeding around in which
a vein is cut the circulatory system
again blood the veins
remember how natural warm blades
spreading with a lot of pressure behind
it a woman which of Danis cut please
quite differently blood escapes in a
slow steady stream and with much less
force the best way to stop this type of
bleeding is by direct pressure on the
bleeding point with a sterile dressing
and are available in various sizes so
that anyone largest small can be
completely covered because the come in
direct contact with the wound dressings
shouldn't be stirred that is free of
bacteria sterile compresses are
available in sealed dust proof packages
to prevent contamination the cob cracks
is placed directly over the wall and
should be large enough to cover the
entire room the bandage is applied to
hopefully compress in place there are a
variety of bandages to the body a very
useful bandage for first aid work if the
triangular bandage which is merely a 36
or 40 inch square of cloth brought it
into a
angle or cut diagonally into two
triangles destined be you to hold a cop
present place on the head scout what
they ate the whole large dressings in
place as for example on the chest the
place over injuries of the hand or foot
to bandage the shoulder and upper arm
when forever for that it can be off to
time splints in place it can also be
used as an arms swing and of course as a
tourniquet don't not apply a triangular
bandage directly many times of our
offenders may be used where a claim for
a bandage is not available this type of
bandage can be used to hold a sterile
compressed or dressing in place devolve
splints in place as a sling for the arm
and as a tourniquet
likewise the roller bandage may be off
in injuries to the arm to baggage and
injured hand in warms of the leg the
ankle to bandage the shoulder and jet to
the head when using a rubber band it
hold it this way and don't know how much
of it to enroll at one time in this
manner you always have control of it all
the keep in mind that any bandage should
be applied firmly enough to keep the
compression place yes not so tight that
it tends to stop the circulation of the
blood for minor wounds the adhesive
compressed bandage taught is very
convenient and has many answers be sure
to remove the protective covering from
the adhesive ends and do not touch this
dog or
and with defendants there are other
types of injury which also require
dressings and sometimes Vantage e of
burdens
a hot stove these are a few of the
finishes fathers of painful burns and
scalds in the case of burns there are
several important things to do treat for
shock dress the burn and call for a
doctor in severe burns after treating
for shock if any of the clothing sticks
to the burned skin get medical attention
at once if ordinary baking soda or
bicarbonate of soda is available make a
solution or a paste with tepid water if
there is some water which has already
been boiled use that apply this solution
or paste gently over a burn then it's
very likely carefully if baking soda and
the other approved burn preparation is
not available cover burns with a sterile
dressing bandage lightly and wait for
the doctor here are just a few don'ts
try not to break open the blister and
don't apply to a burn cotton iodine oils
or greases the first-aid treatment isn't
limited to dressing a wound or burn or
stopping the flow of blood person who
knows first aid can be of help in cases
of unconsciousness an overturned canoe a
running engine behind closed door
door hissing gas just arrived electric
wire they tell what to look for however
in such cases as breathing has stopped
the person may die but given artificial
respiration immediately his breathing
may be restored and his life saved
here's the proper way to give artificial
respiration
Knutson tight clothing to roll him over
place one arm over his head bend the
other arm at the elbow and place the
back of his hand
beside his mouth roll him so that his
head comes to rest on that hand turn his
head upward soon as the nose and mouth
are left free for breathing make sure
the mouth is clear and unobstructed
remove dinner plates or any substances
which may restrict breathing if the
tongue is falling backwards port forward
straddle the victims side now face the
palms of your hands under victim is bet
your fingers should follow the curve of
the ribs with a little finger right over
the lowest rib place your knees below
his hip bone so that when you lean
forward your shoulders are directly over
the small of his back
be sure to assume a comfortable position
swing forward slowly and without bending
your elbows apply the weight of your
body gradually on the victim now this is
step one of artificial respiration and
should take about two seconds all the
time you can count for that's one two
for now release the pressure by swinging
back away from the victim this is step
two this completes one cycle and should
take about five seconds if done properly
artificial respiration should be given
in the continuous operation and with the
proper time one two three four remember
the old song I'll go the bad air in
comes the good air I'll goes the bad air
in comes the good air in some cases it
is worthwhile to continue this treatment
for several hours before giving up hope
if you become tired have someone else
take over taking care that the rhythm is
not interrupted or changed
what's the victims carefully with his
natural breathing returns recovery may
be only temporary and he may again stop
breathing when this happens resumed
artificial respiration immediately treat
the victim for shock as soon as possible
and when he is breathing normally give
him a stimulus and keep him lying
quietly until the doctor arrives
I remember in giving first aid to a
person who's breathing has stopped start
artificial respiration promptly not to
possibly not too rapidly but with a
definite inhalator if available and now
we come to fractures broken bones a
rickety old ladder accurately placed for
a bit of torn carpeting
stepping between parked cars these are
but a few of the causes resulting in
fractures of bulbs where the bone is
broken it may be either a simple or a
compound fracture now here is the
difference here's an x-ray of a simple
fracture the ball is broken but the skin
has not been pierced the area around the
broken bone is usually quite tender and
painful within a short time it'll become
discolored and swollen now here is an
x-ray of a compound fracture more
serious than a simple fracture there is
a connecting wound to the surface in the
immediate vicinity of the brain bleeding
may be severe a tourniquet may be needed
when you suspect a fracture call the
doctor immediately then treat the victim
for shock and
get comfortable and finally if he must
be mourned or if the doctor isn't
available apply a splint as it's a
compound fret chip stop any bleeding and
dress the wound and the pliers splinters
in simple fracture the purpose of a
splint is to hold a limb in a rigid
position and prevent movement which
might aggravate the injury an effective
split is a so-called fixed traction type
the tourniquet is often placed around
the injured member to be ready for use
if bleeding occurs for emergency
purposes in the absence of the traction
splint may serve as a split regardless
of the material used for splitting that
should extend beyond the joints above
and below the fracture if possible it
should also be wide enough to give
adequate support tired of splints
securely but not sous-titres to stop
circulation of the blood examine the
injured part frequently say every 15
minutes if the injured part becomes too
painful or circulation is being cut off
most of the ties around the splint
how many times there is Nano
moving an injured person either because
the doctor isn't available or because of
the location of the accident for
instance in the case of a victim versus
fractured forearm the transportation
problem is relatively simple the forearm
should be splintered before the victim
is moved
however the transportation of a victim
with a more serious fracture presents a
greater problem
in fact the victims should not be moved
unless absolutely necessary or under the
advice of the doctor how many times have
you read of a well-meaning motorist
lifting an injured child from the street
the very way the kind mother lift the
child
jackknifing the child into its car
they of course refers to actors jackets
speakers which might easily the internal
organs whenever there is a fracture of
the lower limbs are other serious
fractures follow these simple rules only
after splint has been applied use a
stretcher adorn all right board will do
if the stretcher isn't available
place the victims carefully onto the
stretcher taking great care not to
twister jar the body keeping lying flat
when carrying the stretcher avoid
unnecessary jarring or swinging
which might aggravate the injury
remember an injured person is at your
mercy treasonous gently and as kindly as
you would like to be treated well you've
seen some of the essentials of first aid
this doesn't make a doctor of you Nora
first an expert but another just first
aid with practice to save a life when
you're nobody knows but at any time and
when you call a doctor
don't forget to give him some detail as
to the nature
of the injury and if you what appear
really good samaratin it's generally a
pretty good idea to let the doctor know
just where the injured person is